un reino ahora bajo control el nombre de
la guerra declarada contra la llamada
agenda Walk el lunes el gobernador de
Florida y potencial candidato
presidencia republicano en 2024 Ron de
santis firmó un proyecto de ley que
comía drásticamente Cómo se gobernará el
parque temático de Disney Florida
durante las últimas cinco décadas un
Distrito fiscal especial ha permitido al
parque de 100 kilómetros cuadrados
operar con un alto grado de autonomía
exento de la mayoría de las regulaciones
estatales
Disney pierde su estatus de autogobierno
el estado de Florida es el nuevo sheriff
de la ciudad
nuestra visión está de acuerdo sí Disney
ya no tiene su propio gobierno pero
tienes que asegurar que todas las leyes
se apliquen tienes que asegurarte de que
la deuda sea pagada y tienes que
asegurarte de que se paga la parte justa
de impuestos la nueva ley autoriza al
gobernador a nombrar a cinco
supervisores para controlar los
servicios municipales allí el año pasado
Disney se enfrentó pública sea de santis
por una ley que restringe la enseñanza
en las aulas sobre género y orientación
sexual muchos analistas políticos
consideran que la nueva legislación es
una represalia forma parte de una
estrategia política de guerra cultural
más amplia empleada por algunos dentro
del partido republicano este analista
Dice que podría tener éxito a corto
plazo pero conlleva riesgos este mensaje
anti despertar es eficaz porque sin duda
es fácil de entender para que la gente
desarrolle una conexión emocional con él
y probablemente animará a algunos a dar
Disney es una gran empresa y esta franja
del partido republicano se está
posicionando en contra de las empresas
lo que es contrario a los propios
objetivos que el partido republicano ha
mantenido durante mucho tiempo y esto es
delicado
Disney ha dicho que no luchará contra
las reformas